pulling off that perfect long range shot
is one of the most satisfying things in
video games we're here to help you
scratch that itch no matter what type of
gamer you are with great games that
either focus on sniping or have amazing
sniping mechanics hit that subscribe
button give us the old thumbs up and
let's get to it when it comes to casual
aaa games that just focus on sniping
they're really two main titles let's
talk about sniper elite first which
largely takes place in world war ii
that's important for comparison and
we'll get back to that in a bit we
played an early preview of sniper elite
5 and also went back to sniper elite 4.
so we'll mostly be talking about those
although there is a zombie and a vr
version of this game the sniper elite
series rides a pretty good line between
stealth challenge and fun it's very
hitman-esque at the highest difficulty
it can be challenging but for the most
part levels are pretty forgiving and you
can get away with a lot
the ai isn't the smartest and they'll do
things like funnel through a door over
and over again most this game is really
about spectacle and anatomy lessons like
that expert kill camp is
be warned
as the series has gone on the tools keep
expanding in the sandbox too they've
added more exploding things for you to
shoot environmental kills and more
recently in 5 weapon customization and
levels with multiple ways to progress
through them so how realistic is the
sniping at lower difficulty levels there
isn't any guesswork involved the game
just tells you where the shot's going to
land so you can think more about how you
want to attack an objective more
interesting though is how the ballistics
change as difficulty increases at easy
and normal there's little bullet drop
and crosswinds don't blow rounds off
target but at hard and hardcore there's
a lot more bullet drop and you have to
account for windage at the highest level
authentic plus the game attempts to
model real world bullet physics
accurately even including things like
air drag you can use general tools
around sniping like using binoculars to
find the range to a target and then dial
that into your scope and use a gamified
wind meter to sort out how much the
bullet will drift left or right to help
you learn all this there's even a test
range sniper lead is a great all-around
sniping game but it's definitely more
for people looking for that fast run and
gun stealth experience it's way more
about spectacle than realism the sniper
gross warrior series started with linear
missions but has opened up into larger
sandboxes with more recent titles like
ghost warrior 3 and contracts 2. ghost
warrior immediately sets itself apart
from sniper elite with a modern setting
that includes gadgets like drones sniper
turrets and bullets that reveal enemies
behind walls this also means modern
weapons and the extensive customization
and gear loadouts that come with it it's
a first person shooter vs sniper elite's
third person first person hybrid system
the series is known for a bit of jank
and sometimes forces you into close
combat which works less well the more
recent title contracts 2 breaks the game
up into classic contracts which play
like the rest of the series and long
range contracts that seem very inspired
by hitman 2 sniper assassin they're more
puzzle based placing the shooter far
away when it comes to how realistic the
sniping is in general the ghost warrior
series near future setting allows the
game to give you all the information you
need to take that shot with very little
guessing that's the most apparent in
contracts too there's a lot shown in
your scope including range wind
direction and speed and even the full
path of the bullet which is kind of cool
in terms of allowing you to understand
that bullets travel in an arc not a
straight line and that changing the
range on your scope just moves where the
arc of the bullet meets the straight
line you see through your scope at the
highest difficulty in contracts 2 called
deadeye you don't have as much
information on screen the range has to
be found with binoculars and there's
less wind data but the game still
basically shows you where the bullet's
going to land using this hatch mark in
the scope that makes it easier than
sniper elite's tougher settings this
game's kill camera doesn't include the
x-ray internal anatomy of elite but it's
still very satisfying
the ghost warrior series is for players
that lean more casual and love weapon
customization making the perfect loadout
and gadgets more than calculating the
perfect shot hitman 2 sniper assassin
originally hitman's sniper challenge was
a pre-order bonus and released as a
stand-alone level ahead of hitman
absolution the idea morphed through a
few iterations including hitman sniper
which is a mobile game version it
finally landed as a mode called hitman 2
sniper assassin for hitman 2. although
this mode is spread across a couple of
different dlc packs you may have to buy
the hitman sniper series is a puzzle
focused game that's more about timing
and using environmental hazards to your
advantage than any kind of actual
shooting simulation it involves the
trademark hitman design of observing a
level and the behaviors and routines of
all the people on it then choosing which
targets to take down in what order
without being noticed as mentioned above
this game has influenced other sniping
games in the industry how realistic is
it the game has basic concepts like
travel time so you'll need to lead
targets if they're moving but that's
about it there doesn't seem to be bullet
drop or windage which means you don't
have to aim high or worry about your
bullets being pushed off target left or
right this is probably the most casual
focused game on the list and it's for
gamers looking to just snipe without
most of the hard parts if you love
observing targets and sorting out that
perfect run
this is your jam
alright multiplayer audience out there
escape from tarkov has blown up in
popularity over recent years a large
part of that being down to the
impressive mechanics and detail in its
gun plane shooting and that extends of
course to sniping the game has a lot of
different rifles featuring different
attachments and firing different types
of ammo which means you can really kid
out a perfect ranged playstyle if you
can afford it if you're in the middle of
the match and you gotta pick up a rifle
off the ground prepare for a lot of
random variables because of the nature
of this game where a single shot can end
anybody's run and when you die you lose
all of your loot sniping has become a
very appealing playstyle sniping offers
a relative amount of safety because you
can keep your distance from both other
players and ai enemies long range kills
are really satisfying but remember this
game has plenty of close combat as well
so make sure you pack a sidearm or pick
up a scav weapon off the ground in case
a pmc gets too close how realistic is
the sniping escape from tarkov adds
realism to sniping but not in the way
you might think it's not so much in the
mechanical operation of a rifle or
ballistics but more the stress a person
has to deal with operating that rifle
under pressure in a high-stakes
confusing and ever-changing environment
a lot of what makes sniping challenging
an escape from tarkov comes from dealing
with enemy players whose movements and
actions are very unpredictable when you
do shoot there are often a lot of
factors to consider while the bullets
you're packing even make it through your
opponent's armor are you going to get a
chance at a follow-up shot is that pmc
alone or in a group or even if you do
get a kill are you going to be able to
safely make it over there to loot this
is pretty different from sniper elite
and ghost warrior being more single
player focused games they avoid this
real world pressure and uncertainty
using flashy kill cameras being
multiplayer you also have to think a lot
more about the fundamentals of movement
and concealment that means don't
silhouette yourself that's where you
clearly stand out against the background
like the sky in terms of ballistics
tarkov does have bullet drop which can
change by ammo type and there's also
travel time so you'll need to lead your
targets finally you have to consider the
environment in your kit a lot more
because if you're fighting at night
you're going to need thermals or night
vision in summary tarkov is for people
that like the stress and pressure of
high stakes sniping and are more
interested in learning about operating
around a rifle more than the mechanics
of the rifle itself oh and if you're
cool with losing all of your stuff when
you die
battlefield you know we had to add it
battlefield 4 was the culmination of
some great sniping mechanics from across
the series with added quality of life
improvements like the ability to dial in
the range and a test island to practice
your craft sniping has always been
fantastically satisfying in the
battlefield series with maps that open
up incredible distances long range
shooting in battlefield has typically
been a lot fairer than in other
multiplayer games because each weapon
has its own velocity and bullet drop
that combined with the fact that in much
of the series but not every game you
have to land a head shot for one hit
kills and it takes practice to get good
at that oh and the hit feedback getting
that hit marker and the kill feed just
the best
[Applause]
the recon class has gone through many
iterations with gadgets like the ability
to call in mortar strikes spawn beacons
and sniper decoys but it's always been
more of a specialized class balanced by
the fact that its secondary weapons were
more limited that's one of the reasons
why the open loadouts of battlefield
2042 didn't really work throw in
hardcore modes and you have yourself a
proper multiplayer sniping pleasure how
realistic is the sniping as a massive
battlefield fan it pains me to say that
the sniping mechanics are just
absolutely all over the place because
each rifle has its own bullet drop
velocity and damage drop off you really
have no way of knowing where your shot's
gonna land each time you start with a
new gun and updates from dice can also
frequently change the handling
characteristics of any weapon in the
game it takes a lot of trial and error
and a lot of practice that's not true
for every game in the series battlefield
4 did allow you to arrange a target with
attachments or using a pld designator
basically fancy binoculars and then dial
that into your scope but it was rarely
useful because of how fast you have to
take shots in a game like this scopes
are only visually modeled after their
real-world counterparts and most of
what's in them can't be used like the
mil-dots and the lines don't really
correspond to the ranges at all
battlefield 1 does have a very cool
mechanic though known as the sweet spot
inspired by real world ballistics that's
where a bullet fired from a bolt action
rifle does maximum damage only between
certain ranges that encourages snipers
to play in their rolls and hang back
despite having insanely satisfying
sniping battlefield has very little
realism though and it's just for fun but
like a lot of fun again this is just for
people who love battlefield love
multiplayer and like a kill feed but
don't need realistic sniping alright
let's get into the hardcore milsim crowd
armor was one of the biggest milsim
games for a very long time and has
countless mods up to ones that make
bullet physics about as real as you can
get in a video game arma is for hardcore
milsim fans that means a lot of time
getting to places sometimes crawling to
places and shooting at dots in the
distance arma and the armor community
have built a selection of missions that
you can play solo pvp or with dozens of
allies against ai i have to warn you
though the control scheme for the game
has never been very friendly and can be
a barrier to entry on its own it can
also be confusing in arma games to fully
understand exactly what you're doing
again you might need somebody to teach
you this is a throwback to when games
were so complex they came with giant
manuals some of you remember that if you
conquer those obstacles arma has always
offered one of the most authentic
military experiences possible if you're
looking to find something that can
simulate what an actual mission might
look like this is your game how
realistic is the sniping with mods it's
so realistic i'm honestly not qualified
to fully break it down and you'd
literally need a shooting course to
fully understand all the math and other
factors like you need to pull out a
shooting computer and do actual math
this one's for people who fully like
milsim they're willing to crawl for long
periods of time to target hang out for a
while do tons of math and then land that
perfect shot
now let's talk about the more recent and
a bit friendlier title squad this route
of project reality mod for battlefield
2. squad is another modern male sim game
and if you choose the sniper roll you'll
be making some tough shots in a player
vs player combined arms environment like
arma the game has mod support including
some realism mods i haven't been able to
spend a lot of time with squad but it
gets recommended a lot when we cover
shooters for now tell me what you think
and we'll break down what we've learned
so far how realistic is the sniping
squad has basic mechanics around
distance shooting you'll have to account
for things like range and bullet drop
one really cool thing that isn't squad
that we haven't talked about in the
other games yet is the scopes are
functional you can actually use a cheat
sheet inside say the pso-1 telescopic
site typically found on dragon of sniper
rifles with this chart you can use the
height of a standing player to find the
range and then use the dots or lines in
your scope corresponding to that
distance for an accurate shot a lot of
games include scopes but the information
inside them is useless and it's
refreshing to have a game where they
actually work there's other ways to do
it too like using binoculars to find the
range and then dialing that into your
scope ballistics in the game beyond that
are good enough for simulation but don't
model very complex railroad forces like
atmospheric pressure windage or air drag
squad has four players that like slower
paced combine arm simulations with a bit
of a learning curve but not something as
complex as arma this is very much an on
mic game and you'll want to play with
friends
short story you don't want to get hit by
it
virtual reality is one of the newer
categories and there isn't a lot there
yet for sniping so if you have a great
vr title with sniper rifles in it let us
know in the comments below before you
run off into the metaverse though here's
some things both good and bad to
consider in sniper elite vr bolt action
guns with scopes can be a challenge the
field of view inside a scope in real
life is narrow and you might spend a
good amount of time trying to line up
your eye with the crosshairs and then
kind of fish around in the environment
looking for bad guys on top of that
holding controllers out in front of you
is inherently shaky compared to using
mouse and keyboard even taking into
account sniper games that have breathing
mechanics it took me some time to settle
in and realize that if i sat down in a
chair i could hold the rifle way more
steady and then oddly enough using my
left eye i could acquire targets much
more quickly that being said there are
great vr quality of life features in
sniper elite vr such as the option to
use teleport movement to keep you from
getting motion sick the thing where you
just pointed objects and yoink them
towards you out of half-life alex and
you can full-on be clumsy and lose your
gun on the ground and just pull another
one out of your backpack the x-ray kill
cam from the main elite series is here
and it totally works as with other vr
titles having to mechanically operate
and reload a vr gun under pressure is a
lot of fun being able to rotate and
fully examine your rifle in your hands
it's something you just can't do on a 2d
screen the sniper elite vr title also
properly translates difficulty from the
base series and it's pretty hard to
brute force your way through with an smg
or an assault rifle because the base
damage is tuned down versus one hit kill
sniper rifles if you're able to overcome
the limitations of vr as always it's
just a cooler more immersive experience
that doesn't necessarily mean better it
just means more present if that makes
sense i really started to enjoy this
game after a couple of levels how
realistic is the sniping the actual
shooting is pretty casual and forgiving
but unlike all the other titles above
you'll be physically aiming manipulating
the gun mechanically operating the bolt
doing simple reloading mechanics all
while being shot at operating the
mechanics of a sniper rifle under
pressure is just something you don't get
outside of er the game is more for
people looking for the novelty of vr and
who can afford the setup it can be very
expensive to get into vr it doesn't add
enough on its own to run out and buy all
the gear but if you already have it you
can have an experience that you just
don't get elsewhere and vr still being
developed it has a lot of potential
it was honestly hard to get this list
down because there are so many great
examples of sniping in video games
there's pretty much something for
everyone depending on what you're
looking for one i had to cut but i want
to just give a big shout out to you
anyway is america's army was this like
tough free great sim that lasted for a
lot of years and i spent a ton of hours
in particular sniping on the snake plane
map so let us know what you're playing
and what you'd like to see next and
honestly let us know what we got right
here and what we got wrong if you play
these games we read the comments and we
use that in our videos alright thanks
for watching everyone
you